It is so decided...
Visible relief after two weeks of intense
negotiations produced a compromise in Katowice
With approximately 200 countries in the room,
it is not easy to find agreement on a deal
so specific and so technical.
Under these circumstances, every single step
forward is a big achievement
The deal sets out rules to implement and finance
the 2015 Paris climate agreement - which aims
to limit global temperature increases to below
two degrees Celsius.
This generation has the responsibility to
show how we keep our planet livable, how we
can make sure that we reduce CO2.
And here we showed the way.
That's important."
But alongside the backslapping there was also
criticism.
Activists were hoping for more ambitious climate
goals - after scientists recently warned that
a cap of 1.5 degrees celcius and a radical
shift away from fossil fuels are needed to
avert disaster.
I think certainly the fossil fuel countries
here slowed things down.
I think that the United States certainly did
not help on the issue of having science move
forward.
But there was just an overall lack of leadership
from the European Union, as well on getting
ambition out of the agreement."
15-year-old Swede Greta Thunberg has become
a voice for the younger generation by inspiring
children all over the world to strike from
school in protest at climate change.
She had sharp words for the adults at the
conference.
You say you love your children above all else
and yet you`re stealing their future in front
of their very eyes.
Until you start focusing on what needs to
be done rather than what is politically possible
there is no hope.
Climate activists - both young and old - feel
world leaders have once again done too little,
too late.
SHUT IT DOWN!!